what are you
doing 43 I'm why are you aiming that
shit at people an unconventional crime
caught on camera when a Utah man points
a toy gun at passing cars and refers to
himself as Satan what's your first name
it's a Satan
Satan yeah yeah that's that's not going
to be a first name for you responding
officers now being praised for their
reaction when the suspect lashed out who
W hey okay
come
here the incident happened on October
23rd in Cottonwood Heights Utah about 20
minutes south of Salt Lake City that's
where officers replied to a 911 call for
a man pointing a toy gun at cars that
were driving by Body camera video shows
officers on the scene approach the
suspect later identified as Sven Oaken
what are you
doing 43
why you aiming that shit at
people put it
down the responding officer asks Oaken
to put away the toy weapon but he pushes
back put it down if you put yours down I
don't have mine out like
you I can I can see it's a toy gun
but come over here with me want to
anywhere with you I'm telling you to
come to my truck I don't want to go to
your truck you're not under arrest okay
still here though okay well then I'm
just going to patch you down for weapons
I don't have anything quit acting froggy
on me just stand there I'm just standing
here I'm just on my way to get some food
okay stay there don't come towards me uh
I'm going to Oaken says the officer is
threatening him before he begins to back
away you're threatening me right now I
am not threatening you you're
threatening my life right now I am not
threatening your life all right do not
come toward me okay stop walking away
from me then do not touch me you promise
let's agree on that you promise don't
touch me okay stand right here I'll
stand right here and don't touch me okay
well I need to at least talk to you
close Oaken then explains he's just on
the way to get some food so what are you
doing I just on my way to get some food
where are you going to get food oh Taco
Bell Taco Bell do you live up here yeah
where do you live I live um Brighton
when the officer asks for his name he
makes a unique Choice saying his name is
Satan and even spelling it out what's
your first name Satan
Satan yeah yeah that's that's not going
to be a first name for you what's your
first
name it's spelled s a t a n I know
that's not your legal name cool he
eventually gives the officer his legal
name and date of birth but not without
some attitude
SV Sven yeah
Sven well it's Greek three okay is that
your first name yeah yeah s v e n what's
your last name uh OPC how do you spell
It O
A yes so word what's your date of
birth that's got a lot of questions
what's your date of birth you don't need
to know that you don't need to know that
yes I do just being boys there no boys
to how old are you you know how old I am
how old are you I have no idea how old
you are how old are you 30 now you tell
me 30 31 31 okay so 92 yeah okay what's
your what's your you know what I'm
talking about don't play with it okay
what's your date of birth 92 is the Year
what's your date and month soon the
focus shifts back to the toy gun okay so
what do you have there just a Nerf gun
yeah you want to show it to me you want
to show me yours no all right then what
are we doing I'm trying to figure out
what you're doing I'm just getting food
okay but we have complains that you're
aiming that at people when they're
driving
by is that not true I did nothing
wrong okay but is it not true or is it
true you aimed it at me when I drove up
you yeah
you you're in the game aren't you what
game fucking play with
you we're being boys don't what we do I
get that okay then I'll see you in round
you're not free to go I am free to go no
you're not then you're threatening my
life I'm not threatening your life
not come back
here I'm free to go then there's nothing
wrong with you there's nothing
wrong3 n but I'm going for 99
now I'll keep it all in my
pants I'll keep it in my pants and we'll
be
good no h no fuck we're walking towards
Classy Chassis Car
Wash okay why are you moving cuz you're
acting like I'm under arrest and I'm not
I I'm not I didn't say you're under
arrest you're acting real shady but
you're detained I'm not detained yes you
are no I'm not I'm just doing my thing
you're doing your thing I'll keep it in
my pants if people are complaining yeah
well they are complaining so I'm just
trying to figure out what you're doing I
was playing I was
playing just stay right here I was
playing a little bit of War I didn't
know that was going to offend
anybody you're playing a little bit of
War okay I don't know what this is I
don't like it well you don't we're not
going to hurt you you don't have to like
it but you need to stop where but
suddenly Oaken pulls the toy out again
there's a struggle and soon the body
camera slams to the
ground hey okay come
here I did nothing wrong get on the
ground I did nothing wrong get on the
ground hey what are you doing get on the
ground what are you doing J that's what
are you doing you're on the ground I'm
right here get that shit off me hey give
me your hey what are you doing what are
you doing what are you
doing at that point Oaken is arrested
what the is this
obviously you're under arrest no I'm
not you're not going to kick me in the
body
King get off me get your sh off me
kicking my back get your off
me get your off
me get your sh off me get him
boys you're hurting me you're
threatening me you're kicking my back
I'm just sitting here get off me
get off me where you
at easy easy we can all sit down
together normal that ain't happening why
cuz you wanted to hurt someone you're
the I'm hurting you you punched me
yeah get your off me quiet get your off
me you're hurting
me you're trying to hurt me threatening
me nobody's hurting I will destroy you
guys you're the one kicking me I can't
breathe I got one I can't breathe ow
help help me help me help me instead of
calming down though Oaken begins
screaming at the team of officers on the
scene what are you
doing what are you
doing what are you doing that's what I'm
trying to figure out I'm just going to
eat not anym you're not what are you
talking about get
your want like you're hurting me you're
hurting me St hurting me stop that what
yourself stop
ground get off
me get off me get out of my
shit get out of my
[Music]
sh you want to kick me in the nuts I'll
kick you in
the all right we're going try to flip on
this way you ready yeah which way I'll
just sit stand what are you
doing what are you doing what are you
doing what are you doing my head get off
my head I'm pinning you down get off my
head there you go get off my head get
off my head get off my
head
okay then video captures him making
another strange statement about killing
someone and using a bomb you're all dead
all right and you know that I killed
them
boys it was easy man I haven't seen you
in so long I killed him and it was
easy I just used a
bomb the video ends with Oaken still
struggling with officers you are not
relaxing at all dude that's cuz I'm not
sitting in my thr you laying down in a
nice angle where you can breathe with a
cool grass on your face let's get me my
happy
throne
grass me sit it's a grassy if you speak
that you know
that halfs what's
that then what happened I was just gang
banging pistol swanging and this guy
shows up pistol swinging bro Oaken was
later charged with assault possession of
marijuana interference with a peace
officer and disorderly conduct reporting
for long crime Network I'm CR Gillespie